well for more now on this week's
testimony and what's ahead in the
chauvin trial we're joined by cbs news
legal analyst ricky kleeman ricky good
morning
good morning let's start here week one
wrapped with
expert testimony from the prosecution
many of whom
those witnesses on the stand were law
enforcement focusing on use of force
how effective were they if you look at
week one
we had all of the emotional anguish
testimony of the bystanders
week two was expert witness week and it
followed the two potential defenses
in this case the defense led in its
opening statement by saying
that the cause of death was not from
derek chauvin's knee upon the neck of
george floyd
but was due to heart disease complicated
by drug use
the other defense had to do with the
fact of excessive force
with the defense saying no no no what he
did was not excessive it was within the
training
and that is why those two defenses are
so
important so what does the prosecution
do it leads with the training issue
and they had witness after witness who
was
there to give powerful and yet detached
testimony not as emotional but certainly
full of fervor about what derek chovin
did
as being outside the training clearly
unnecessary
and ultimately excessive force
ricky how damning is police testimony in
a case like this and
some have said there were too many use
of force
experts called do you agree with that
look there are only too many experts
called on a subject if the trial runs
long
so these jurors were promised a trial
that they would be seated as jurors for
three to four weeks
if the case ends within three or four
weeks which is what i fully expect
nothing is going to be held against the
prosecution for having multiple
witnesses
each witness offered a little bit more
and when you have the chief of police
that exceptional testimony that we
ordinarily don't see
from someone who talks about values
talks about ethics that has to be mighty
powerful indeed
this is the chief for these jurors
he is certainly an admirable figure
ricky the other part of the case that
you mentioned was that medical testimony
which we also saw
how damning was that testimony as well
and then how does the defense go about
countering it
well to say the prosecution had a good
week is my understatement of the morning
they had an exceptionally
good week and why because they had
witnesses
who were highly qualified and were very
clear about their opinions
when you have a pulmonologist like dr
tobin come
in and literally have a dialogue almost
with this jury in the sense
that he had them do demonstrations when
he asked them
to touch their necks and to feel certain
parts of their body
most of the jurors did it he had
diagrams
he had animation he was a mesmerizing
witness
to come to the horrendous conclusion
that it was this oxygen deprivation
by the weight of derrick chauvin
on the back and on the neck of george
floyd
and that no one could have survived that
kind
of weight and then when you have two
wonderful
witnesses as pathologists who are
virtually
unimpeachable in dr thomas and the
medical examiner dr baker
who are clear that george floyd would
not have died if he did not have
this intervention from law enforcement
they had a great week the defense has
its work cut out for it for next week
ricky we appreciate the insight thank
you